-Performing "Shaq & Kobe"
from their new album
"Too Good to Be True,"
along with their hit "Ima Boss,"
give it up
for Rick Ross and Meek Mill!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-Hunh!
♪♪
>> [ Echoing ] Maybach Music...
Maybach Music...
-Hunh.
-What is this?
-It's "Too Good to Be True,"
in stores right now
and on streaming platforms.
-Maybach Music.
-I go by the name of Meek Milly.
-Ricky Rozay.
♪♪
[ Both speaking indistinctly ]
-...for the dream chasers...
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ People wanna see you lose ♪
♪ When you're makin' moves ♪
-♪ Moves ♪
-♪ We bringin' tools
in any rooms ♪
-♪ We tryna break the rules ♪
-♪ Rules ♪
-♪ ...is haters,
they ain't goons ♪
-♪ We tryna make a fool ♪
-♪ Fool ♪
-♪ I never thought
I'd make the Forbes ♪
-♪ Before I made the news ♪
-♪ Never ♪
-♪ Havin' a threesome
with some women ♪
♪ It still ain't amusin' ♪
-♪ No ♪
-♪ I pick and choose,
put on my jewels ♪
♪ It's like I lit the fuse ♪
-♪ It's lit ♪
-♪ I call the shots,
and all the...be like ♪
♪ "What's the move?"
-♪ Let's get it ♪
-♪ Hundred grand,
you and your little man
♪ Getting split in two ♪
-♪ Getting split in two ♪
-♪ Whoo ♪
-♪ My life got way realer ♪
-♪ Playin' with them millions,
♪ And it turned me
into a made... ♪
-♪ Anywhere in the trenches,
I be active when they play... ♪
♪ ...got retracted when...ratted
'cause we sprayed... ♪
♪ Mafioso, sippin' Lobos ♪
-♪ Lobos ♪
♪ Jumpin' out the chopper to
the yacht off the Gold Coast ♪
♪ We was totin' choppers
on the block, sellin' coco ♪
♪ Now we treatin' models like ♪
♪ They thots out in SoHo ♪
-♪ Out in SoHo ♪
-♪ Thirty mill' in cash ♪
♪ Do these haters bad ♪
-♪ Bad ♪
-♪ They never thought
I'd go this far ♪
-♪ Just from a pen and pad ♪
-♪ Hunh ♪
-♪ I seen my dawg kill my dawg,
just to get his stash ♪
♪ He went up top,
they banged him out ♪
♪ We got that hater splash ♪
-♪ Too much ♪
-♪ Whoa ♪
-♪ Too much money and power ♪
♪ Walk up in the spot,
a bunch of steppers ♪
♪ We tuckin' the choppers ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Too much money and power ♪
-♪ Hunh ♪
-♪ Hustlin' 24 hours ♪
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-If you got love for the MMG,
make some noise tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Hit records --
"Too Good to Be True"
in stores now.
-One time for...M.I.A.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yeah!
♪ Look, I be riding
through my old hood ♪
♪ But I'm in my new whip ♪
-♪ Yes ♪
-♪ Same old attitude,
but I'm on that new...
♪ They say they gon' rob me ♪
-♪ Rob me ♪
-♪ See they never do, 'cause
they know that's the reason ♪
♪ They gon' end up
on a news clip ♪
-♪ Brrrrp, brrrrp, brrrp ♪
-♪ Audemars on my wrist ♪
♪ Bust down ♪
-♪ Bust down ♪
-♪ We poppin' bottles
like I scored the winning... ♪
-♪ Touchdown ♪
-♪ 'member me dead broke? ♪
-♪ Broke ♪
-♪ Look at me up now ♪
-♪ Up now ♪
-♪ I run my city
from South Philly ♪
♪ Back to Uptown ♪
-♪ Uptown ♪
-♪ Thank God all these ♪
♪ Bottles I popped ♪
-♪ Bottles I popped ♪
-♪ All this paper
I been getting ♪
♪ All these models I popped ♪
♪ I done sold
a hundred thousand ♪
♪ 'fore my album got dropped ♪
-♪ Album got dropped ♪
-♪ And I'm only 23 ♪
-♪ Whoa, whoa ♪
-♪ Look at me,
look at me, I'm a boss ♪
♪ Like my homie Rozay ♪
-♪ Rozay ♪
-♪ Shawty asked me for a check ♪
-♪ I told that chick ♪
-♪ No way ♪
-♪ 'cause I made it
from the bottom ♪
♪ It was never no way ♪
-♪ And I never had a job,
you know I had to sell yay ♪
-♪ Here come the boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
♪ I call the shots ♪
-♪ Call the shots ♪
♪ I'm with the murder team ♪
-♪ Murder team ♪
♪ Call the cops ♪
-♪ Call the cops ♪
-♪ We in the building ♪
-♪ Y'all are not ♪
-♪ You short on the paper,
you gon' ball or not? ♪
♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
-♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
♪ I plan the shots ♪
-♪ Hunh! ♪
-♪ I call the calls ♪
-♪ We in this building ♪
♪ It's goin' down ♪
-♪ It's goin' down ♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm the king, now where
my mother effing crown? ♪
♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
-♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I plan the shots ♪
-♪ Pump it, Rozay ♪
-♪ I call the calls ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Let's hit it ♪
-♪ Got so many shades,
they thought I had a lazy eye ♪
♪ Shawty rode me
smooth as my Mercedes ride ♪
-[ Sings indistinctly ]
-♪ No love,
cry when only babies die ♪
♪ And when I go, that casket
better cost a hundred thou ♪
♪ I pray to God I look my killer
in his eyes ♪
♪ Snatch his soul
out his shirt ♪
♪ Let's take him for that ride ♪
-♪ Come on ♪
-♪ OG is one who's standing
on his own feet ♪
♪ A boss is one who guarantee
we gon' eat ♪
♪ ...a blog, dawg,
'cause one day we gon' meet ♪
♪ I'm-a spaz on your...
like I'm Monique ♪
♪ Or a double stack,
bet yo' boy double that ♪
♪ Jerry Jones, lil boy,
you just a running back ♪
♪ Herschel Walker ♪
-♪ What? ♪
-♪ Bo Jack ♪
-♪ What else? ♪
-♪ Ricky Watters,
better run that dope... ♪
-♪ Boss ♪
-♪ And I put that
on my Maybach ♪
-♪ Maybach ♪
-♪ Four hundred thou, chick,
you wish you saved that ♪
-♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I plan the shots ♪
-♪ Plan the shots ♪
-♪ I call the calls ♪
-♪ Call the calls ♪
-♪ We in this building ♪
-♪ It's goin' down ♪
-♪ You understand,
I need my mother effing crown? ♪
♪ Say I'm a boss ♪
-♪ I'm a boss ♪
-♪ Scared money
don't make no... ♪
-♪ If I ever go broke,
I'm-a take your money ♪
-Jimmy Fallon! Make some noise!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Too Good to Be True"
in stores now, baby.
We love you.
-Oho!
Yes!
-Thank you. Appreciate you.
-That's how you do it, buddy.
Yo! Come on.
That is how you do it, bud.
Rick Ross! Meek Mill!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
"Too Good to Be True"
is out now!